today so many I'm only occupying the
stage just for a moment to thank Mark
for e for a yet again doing a wonderful
thing in the gallery and I remember that
I know a little bit of the history of
this one I remember Felicity saying
something about this amazing show and I
got to see the show myself when when I
was over there and so I'm sort of super
happy that it arrived here and and it
remains of course a kind of key question
what it means open forum and even if
there's a contradiction in terms that
was played with Brian Henson starting
more or less in the year I was born so
for some reason i think i have a kind of
tragic relationship to this concept and
but it's a concept that moves in such an
interesting way from a heavy-duty
architectural frame to what could be
thought of as an art frame through a
kind of experimental film practice but
but all along the way none of those
contexts seem adequate to it like
architecture doesn't seem to fully grasp
the term and maybe it was designed to
resist architecture so it was of course
that it would sort of it was slip out of
the grasp of the architects first but I
think it also almost equally quickly
slides away from from art and the
teaching of art and it did become very
important in the teaching about and
likewise with film so it's a sort of an
elusive concept that's a very very
seductive so it gets picked up by people
and the people who pick it up are
absolutely defined by the fact that
they're not boring so a series of
extremely interesting people sort of
fall in love with this concept which
ultimately escapes them and so in a way
it holds itself through from
architecture through wire through
experimental film and beyond and and
therefore exists as a kind of hypothesis
about an alternative
alternative practice so it's a sort of a
concept that's more interesting than
anyone who's ever picked it up and may
have been in a certain sense more
interesting than handsome themselves and
I think that that no matter how
brilliant Hanson was I think what's
truly brilliant as always to come up
with something that's more interesting
than you are and it happens all the time
like if you're obsessed with things like
I am like making the perfect coffee
there is a moment in which it happens
you make it but you can it's better than
you because you can never repeat it and
so I think concepts that are better than
people become better than departments
and better in the fields and then and
then then really become pedagogical
instruments and surely open forum is
exactly of that order so i think it's
potentially extraordinarily healthy for
the school to as it were bring it back
like bring it back through the loop and
stage again the question open forum back
in an architectural concept of course we
may we may not learn the lesson as well
as we should because we are so fatally
attracted to and addicted to art and
protect in particular experiments
between architecture and art so i think
that this exhibition is also very
interesting in the X in the ways in
which it continues our exploration of
the all too solid line between
architecture and art so I think it's
just yet another kind of healthy meal
that marketers friends are providing but
anyway hand you over to my but also just
to say that those of you who have come
with Mike to do this we super welcome
the collaboration and also the kinds of
questions that are coming going to come
out of this and if if this exhibition is
a success as I know it will be we will
not be able to exhibit the same way in
that space again and so I think it's
it's it's potentially even without
knowing it going to kind of alert us to
things that go on in the Arthur Ross
gallery and as you know the arthrosis
gallery has been one of the very very
central sides for the school to reflect
upon itself and its
and so on so in in their kind of classic
way it is an extremely closed form the
Ross gallery could not be more closed
the windows a shut up shut off the
building did move by the way they're
just as piece of small history that the
buell building is the oldest building in
Columbia and it was not there it was
down at what would be now more or less
the bottom of the steps of low library
so actually the building itself moves so
watch out even though if even if the
authorized gallery is very very a very
precisely defined space and therefore
it's a good space for thinking about the
way open forum subverts closed spaces
weirdly enough that building once in an
insane asylum and once again tonight
another insane asylum is on the move as
potentially on the move anyway just to
say it's a good thing that's happening
and thank you tomorrow Thank You Dean
Whitley just one small correction then
there's something in the nature of the
open forum project for Hanson and among
his followers that is invested in ideas
of see reality and process and
repetition so it's not surprising that
mark you might think that this is the
same exhibition that appeared in Europe
but in fact it's the result of intensely
new archival research on behalf of some
of us and especially wakacje and Natalia
in Poland and me long distance and we'll
talk about that a little bit because
there's something about the nature of
open forum that leads to these ideas but
I think it's just important to point out
that because these exhibitions are
incredibly exciting but laborious and
painful process is the archive is our as
ever resists you know our incursions
but this is just to say that they're all
kinds of thanks and acknowledgments do
and and because although mark said he
was not going to offer much on open
forum he's already said everything I
have to say so I we want to
acknowledgments no but it's important to
note that the exhibitions that we do in
the gallery are produced under the
constraints that one normally associate
with the University gallery and as a
result the exhibition was only possible
with the absurd devotion of many people
that I would like to acknowledge here
i'd like to acknowledge and thank the
trust for mutual understanding and
Carrie Thompson for the support for
producing the exhibition we'd like to
thank yo la jolla at the Museum of the
Academy of Fine Arts worse off for the
loan of documents and her archival
assistance the art artist Sofia kulick
has been an incredibly enthusiastic and
generous contributor to the exhibition
and as ever the exhibition was produced
only because of the extraordinary
determination commitment of the
exhibition's crew and this year's
exhibitions assistance and Coons and
Luca farinelli Adam bandler the CCCP
exhibitions assistant has been heroic
working with me and the other curators
organizing designing and producing the
exhibition and Natalia Shanna bitch who
is assistant curator the exhibition
worked closely and untiring with me and
lukasz researching and preparing the
exhibition and as Mark suggested I'd
like to something in this narrative
belongs to fizzle velicity she first
introduced me to lukasz somewhere in the
east village and so in a sense she is
the instigator of this project and
finally of course to caution due to my
collaborator on this exhibition and as
market also suggest that the exhibition
falls under at least two GSAT categories
the first is the living archive which is
a series of exhibitions we have
developed at a school focusing on
important and under examined
architectural archives and it also falls
under a newer category that we're
following the global experiments and art
and architecture initiative so aptly as
is obvious from the title the exhibition
hinges around the interaction between
art and architecture specifically around
the work of art the architect oscar
hansen and his theory of open forum and
how this is translated interpreted and
appropriated by his students at the
Warsaw Academy of Fine Arts and before
we talk about that in sight more detail
I want to return to my collaborator
lukasz renew de because as much as a
brief introduction to the exhibition
would have to not only mention something
of open forum we would have to mention
something abou kasia's continued
provocation to those of us who did not
know the work of Polish artists in the
1670s and this provocation comes in two
parts in the first part similarities to
work that we might know here in the so
called West is author and then just as
this similarity appears obvious indeed
inescapable a reverse procedure occurs
and in this despite such obvious
similarities the political and social
context a Poland in the post-war is
articulated which means that these
similarities which we thought we had
discovered deserve to be scrutinized and
doubted and so this operation is much
more than a simple comparison more than
a contrasting analysis it is something
much more hallucinatory uncanny a kind
of simultaneous familiarization and D
familiarization of the work and
something of this process is at work
also in the appearance of open forum in
the exhibition and as Dean Wiggly is
also suggested open forum appears first
in the work of Oscar Hanson Oscar Henson
architect of well-known project student
appears on array for knowledge a
participant at team 10 meetings in
Arthur Lou 1959 and banyan
nineteen sixty where he delivers open
forum as something which is not so
unrecognizable as a critique which is to
say not so unrecognizable and familiar
to us as a critique of modernist dogma
then at some point through his teaching
at the fine arts academy and through the
work of a student in his own later work
open forum emerges of something if not
stranger and not more interesting than
at least something much more exploratory
and something that opens a series of new
directions for Hanson and for the
artists that follow until in a sense
this is the trajectory that the
exhibition is also going to follow and
so when we talk about this transition
just a few images to illustrate this is
Oscar Hanson describing the relationship
between the small number and the large
number but also the relationship between
open and closed for this is a series of
didactic images of didactic exercises or
apparatuses that Oscar Hanson had his
students develop their approach to open
forum through at the academy of fine
arts this is an installation of an
exhibition at called the redoubt room in
1957 one of the early instances of
Hanson's use of open forum and this is a
slightly later version of it and I'll
talk about these images in a second this
is an image that belongs to the linear
continuous system project and then this
is how open forum begins to appear in
the work of his followers this is a
still from the film game on an actress's
face 1971 this is from mercury by kulick
1975 this is a still of Oscar Hanson in
action participating in a collective
event that was filmed for the
documentary feeling or groping one's way
as it's been more provocatively
translated and this is from the
collective project game and more else
he'll
and this from Studio A another film an
open in the open forum genre so the open
forum and closed form are just the
beginning of a large lexicon that one
would need in order to start to
understand these projects but just a
little bit more about open forum open
forum for Hanson emerged in reaction to
the pathologic on limiting condition he
described as closed form perhaps in the
latter category characterized both a
modernist doctrine of standardization
into perfect ation that he argued
delivered hermetic monuments unable to
react to creative input from inhabitants
and users as well as many aspects of the
post-war architectural social yoga in
Poland Hanson postulated that open
former deliver a flexible architecture
as well as a mode of communicative
interaction and participant
participation sensitive to the role of
individuals and to individual video sync
receives within the composition of a
collective and it's important to hear
this idea of an individual participate
in a collective especially in looking at
the work of his students and followers
that come after responsible responsive
to local urban or natural conditions
open forum would be capable of
transformation growth in evolution and
appropriately Hanson's own conception of
an application of open forum was self
transforming with various manifestations
and strategies at a range of scales and
you see this in the work from the small
gallery installations to the very large
linear consist linear continuous system
indeed scalability was one of its
central tenants while the first open
forum experiments were a series of
small-scale installations the largest
reach occurred through plans for the LCS
and the LCS was developed as a series of
proposals that was intended to
reorganize patterns of transportation
and inhabitation along linear
trajectories following an evolutionary
growth process that would help overcome
boundaries forms of control and
eventually systems of land ownership so
the linear continuous system
as the largest instance of open forum
would elicit collective participation
and as well complete displacement of
geopolitical control systems so you see
something about the ambitions attached
to open forum I believe what cash is
going to say much more on this lexicon
that I hinted at but just to deliver a
few of the terms that would be necessary
to make sense of the open forum
adventure working with a camera camera
provocation interrupted projection
revealing the complex form etc etc you
know there's a kind of a veritable
scientific handbook of terminology that
is helpful in really understanding the
precision of the experiments that the
artists were working through so with
that I'm going to move on to an
introduction to tonight speakers we're
going to have four brief presentations a
small conversation some questions and
then we will go over to see that show
velicity Scott is going to speak first
Felicity you all know faculty member
author and widely published and director
of the CCCP program critical conceptual
and curio to a curatorial practices here
at G sap lukasz the my collaborator on
the exhibition will follow Luca she's a
scholar curator author widely published
but most recently his his new book is
just come out polish art of the 1970s
chrissy isles will follow chrissy is the
curator of film and video with a win
music again numerous publications
catalog and exhibitions including most
recently i believe a curator co-curator
of the retrospective of and Graham's
work beyond and we're going to finish
with Anton video clay artists widely
exhibited venice biennale Tate Modern
etc and he is also the founder of the
famous you flux thank you
okay can have the first image please
thank you thanks Markham prefer a
fantastic exhibition I haven't seen the
very final form that it was suddenly
looking spectacular earlier in the day
and so I've been asked to focus on Oscar
Hanson and just want to offer some some
brief remarks something on the concept
of open forum but also why it might have
translated so effectively from the
experimental architectural context into
that of these artistic games or visual
games and and for camera activities
which I'm sure what cash will talk to in
more detail that characterized the work
of the students of the war Thor fine
arts academy and I just wanted to say
that in some regards these these these
archival films and slide works not only
speak to the remarkable history of
polish film at this moment but also
really are for one of the most
provocative examples of the legacy of
Hanson's thinking so Hanson as Mark
mentioned first presented the open forum
thesis exactly called the open forum in
architecture the art of the greater
number at the 1959 CM conference in Auto
low and event of course that mark the
the demise of this modernist institution
and the emergence of team 10 and many
members of Team 10 would quickly pick up
on Hanson's on Hanson's concept even if
not always giving him credit for it what
I want to do is just to set out to sort
of interrelated aspects of his thesis
that I think informed the artistic games
that are captured in these films first
and less frequently acknowledged as he's
concerned with transforming excellent
relations between the individual and the
collective that Marcus udah mentioned an
old theme we might note but one that
would take on a particular valence in
since work and so with respect to
developing housing type ologies for the
so-called greater number or the
multitude he stressed the importance of
dressing concrete people not the
so-called abstract average and so Hansen
proposed them that that individuality
individuality had become what he called
lost in the collective and that the
individual stands apart from the action
and what he meant by this and what his
response was to this was in the first
instance to make those individuals sort
of legible or visible as differentiated
elements of the collective open forum
then as he argued would be manifest by
the discernible nas's his room at least
in translation the discernible mess of
the individual in the multiple and the
discernible pneus in turn of the number
of the multitude so such discernible
pneus then we could say would be at once
a visual or a formal phenomena you know
the sort of visual registration of
difference within a larger field as well
as the result of a type of memory
produced through bodily participation
within a process that would is later as
henton would later stress be produced to
a type of bodily participation within a
process that would be part of a type of
a psychological aspect of his ambitions
or he talked about at helping us define
ourselves and find our place in the
space and time we live in and in the
second instance his aim was to make that
individual of course an operative player
in this action when he said that the
individual had been divorced from the
action or in Hanson's words to make him
indispensable in the creation of his own
surroundings and so central then to what
Hanson would call a completely new
architectural task was the communication
of radical heterogeneity that the
subject would both produce visually and
spatially through their actions and
interactions
also that incorporates psychologically
as a form of defense against the
totalizing forces of that greater number
and such differentiation would lead or
would not lead does not lead to the
isolation of individuals in space but
would give rise to what he referred to
as a type of continuous space or group
form that would be comprised of
individuality but would not eliminate
conflicts or his words polemics but
rather see these conflicts as part of
the engine of transformation and so
Hanson recognized them that establishing
this type of participatory role in the
creation of one surroundings was not at
all a simple task yeah there would be
subject of course to ongoing process
ease of negotiation and as such that it
would involve people within a political
process second and closely related open
forum entailed not only a move away from
the design I think I skipped an image
here we'll come back to this of a fixed
or finite object your seating aspects of
this to the user but also a register and
shift to the question of the
interrelation between elements and even
disciplines and hence to the notion of
environment and in a recent interview
Hanson recounted that in Auto Lou he
said I didn't really understand the
significance of what I was doing I was
doing something and suddenly it turns
out that it's called environment in 1971
then just a couple of years after he'd
begun to take his students out of the
visual structures studio for the open
air seminars he amounts somewhat
unexpectedly that and I quote the idea
of architecture and plastic art based on
the open design stems from the
principles of the situationist movement
also calling for the active
collaboration of the user in order to
capture what he called the unfolding
process of life itself and so it's taken
up in form as in many other process
re-entered and event-based practices of
the 60s and 70s was the question of how
to produce a work without of course prix
determining its final form how to set
out something like a minimal structuring
system such as a script or a set of
constraints that would facilitate
interaction
did sense forms of participation without
determining their nature and which would
allow for these this sense of openness
of transformation and even I wanted to
stress something like feedback so indeed
these strategies then with their ideals
of fostering new paradigms of
communication and social exchange we're
very much indebted to an encounter with
cybernetic and information technologies
the games at times almost mimicking the
at once recursive and largely
indeterminate structures of
post-industrial technologies and so
you'll hear these images suggest the
language of communication theory at work
and when the artists reflect and the
modes of interaction taking place
between them and so here we find one of
the oddest saying to the other I am
transmitting you are receiving and they
know that a condition of their
participation then is that they will a
van abandon their obtrusive I or II go
elsewhere i think translators intrusive
so that means that they are their
actions in some sense have become relay
points within a type of communication
network their messages cast of course a
sort of packets of information
circulating within these systems and we
also find in filling ones way which mark
should an image off we find hanson
himself invoking the rhetoric of
communication theory and making
distinctions between a sort of
uni-directional communication of
traditional messages and in his words
and i quote communication as a form of
exchange between two or more people
where because of their multi
directionality the message is enriched
significantly broadening the sphere of
communication again the sort of
indeterminacy of being the product of a
type of encounter and so then this
experience of a rapidly transforming
technological milia which was sense then
of the exacerbated rate of obsolescence
not only in the technological domain but
also in crucial to Hansen's work as an
architect in its social carlot yeah so
what hansen refers to his closed formed
head in this sense come to seem
anachronistic since in his words it had
not accepted that
changes in the modes of life and had
become obsolete before it was even
realized you know so that is it couldn't
sponsor use social relations so I just
want to quickly go through a couple of
the projects I'm not going to speak to
this one but but just to begin by saying
that although Hanson would continue to
privilege these large-scale planning
projects such as the linear continuing
continuous systems when he talked about
the objectives of open forum especially
later on that the concept was tested out
most effectively at the scale of
interventions and interactions with with
artistic environments with gallery
spaces on the like and in a recent
interview he recalled that everything
started with the exhibition pavilions
it's the micro scale that they were very
important the only thing but the micro
scale they were very important as a
moment in the history of open forms yes
he continued exhibitions with the
laboratory of open forum and so for the
Polish pavilion that you see here at the
shmira International Festival of 55
hansen and his collaborator Tomashevsky
devised this modular system of eight by
eight metre hyperbolic paraboloid
tensile structures that they called the
HT system after their names which
produced this type of dense visual space
and enhance and referred to this as
almost like a type of surface with
machines and people being displayed and
sort of working amongst them he said
this is what I call the experience of
the background his pavilion a few years
later in San Paolo even some senses sort
of formally reminiscent of the
predecessor at a shmear had undergone a
very important change so unlike sort of
fixed module of the bits of pavilion
what he called this biotechnical
structure was transform a ball and
non-modular in its geometry its form
shifting gently with the wind and other
forms of participation so in other words
it was conceived of as more responsive
to its environment and as Hansen's
remarkable diagram of the lower-right
suggest yeah the the the point here is
the production of a type of
heterogeneity
yeah but logic at work being that a
facilitating this form of
differentiation and this this
adaptability was perhaps even more
literally carved into gallery projects
first the 1958 attendance I can't
pronounce section gallery in which
through providing movable walls and
floor levels within steel frame cube the
design is sought to offer the curators
and artists what they call total freedom
for the design of the enclosed space and
so we find that with the institutional
space of the museum no longer constraint
and the form or scale of artistic
production that the building my in
Hanson's words assist the birth of the
art of the Future II of this is it's
more utopian dimension and Hanson's
competition entry in turn for the Museum
of Modern Art in skokie of 66 forms a
related experiment surely we might say
one of the strangest ideas for a museum
the hydraulically powered hexagonal
modules of this transformable
environment could be multiplied deployed
and redeployed as gallery spaces then
withdraw or attract completely
underground in this design fair thought
to produce the type of animated
buildings in Hanson's words it would be
like space growing out of the ground
like a tree and so I wanted to distress
them at the heart of these two gallery
projects was the new type versus of you
register functionalist thinking one no
longer premise an optimized relation
between form and function or between
space and programmers had been of
idealized in aspects of modernism but
one that would be um would be updateable
a transformable and here we find
ourselves then at the very crux of a
modernist architectural problematic you
know this sort of fannish fantasy of
short-circuiting the threat posed to the
disciplines role in giving material an
aesthetic form to social needs you know
the threat that was inherent to this
sort of exacerbated rate of obsolescence
and seemingly solved through the
capacity of a perpetual transformation
evinced a type of mourning for the
integrity of those relations moreover of
Hansen's architecture
up until scoffs you be conceptually
striving towards the indeterminate and
flexible logics of electronics and
cybernetic control mechanism here that
relation would take on a new dimension
yes oh the museum's modules were
literally to be electronically
controlled by the artist he said this
electronically controlled gallery
instrument goes beyond the rich
potential for exposition in itself by
again provoking a new art sculpting an
architectural space live before the eyes
of a public to create visual
performances you know again a sort of
utopian dimension to the world and so
within the context of architecture more
generally we might say that such an
appeal to open-endedness and
indeterminacy can be read as an attempt
to constitute a refusal of architectures
capacity to program also to invest a
space or environment with enormity of
logic and with that a certain
disciplinary and ideological function
with respect to dominate techniques of
power and in turn to uncouple or break
open this relation certainly in
attempting to see the authority of the
architect to the user by making them a
participant in the construction of their
environment was in principle understood
as a means to overcome this determinate
and functional logic and open prospects
for a different type of environment but
also and crucial to Hanson for new forms
of subjectivity and political agency
within it but I wanted to suggest that
if Hanson might have been correct that
architecture could in principle serve as
a site or as a type of prosthetic from
micro political forms of engagement in a
larger environment if he was right in
believing that the subject gained a
level of agency and self-reflection
through interaction weather or the
completion of a transformable object
that this promise and certainly insofar
as translated into large buildings was
in the first instance largely foreclosed
by architectures very materiality and
the economic scale of such
transformation and this would of course
be the case not only in Poland but
within most mecca structural projects
such as the Pompidou in Paris but in
addition with these galleries I wanted
to suggest that the artists
or curator heading turn beings of recast
as something like a programmer yeah
controlling the form of an environment
that no longer took a particular
particular organization without their
participation and as such that that it
was an environment that potentially
facilitated and ever more sort of
exacting or precise management of those
relations between the subject and space
IE that it was not simply an open space
but a space now managed digitally and as
such potentially even further closed so
we might speculate then that the
translations are we might speculate that
the translation of open form from
architectural and exhibition projects to
one based in games or performance works
and their filmic documentation meant
that open forum had found a more
appropriate site or medium in which to
be actualized here these gave and served
of course to sponsor new articulations
of collective social activity in which
art was staged as an environmental
practice in which the environment was
understood the type of field of
communication so again unlike these
projects requiring massive state
sponsorship such as the housing estates
which could quickly close down these
practices could occupy the interspecies
of an often technocratic and at times
repressive political move yer were
producing a certain spacing or opening
within them perhaps even new modes of
political engagement but I also want to
say that to simply attribute this to
these other media is to have perhaps to
too quickly overlook the degree to which
open forum was equally invested in
fostering experimentation in modes of
expression that might model these new
forms of collective social relations or
modes of interaction and so to this end
you might recall that Hanson's thesis
operated simultaneously at many levels
yes openness appeared not only in the
realm of flexibility and formal
composition that achieved to these
transformable components within a system
but also visually registering relations
between the individual and the
collective as well as within the modes
of social interaction between subjects
and their environment in so it typically
conceived then within architecture as
I from formal flexibility wanted to
suggest that open forum can also operate
quite independently of any type of
transformable infrastructure even at a
conceptual level and that other modes of
interaction remained yes that we can
think then of openness certainly as a
type of indeterminacy not simply a form
but also in this register of social
relations as Hanson proposed thank you
good evening I will speak about
political context of the works we are
showing at our exhibition and especially
I will talk about Scott Howson students
of your cool and Gemma so archaic who
formed this artistic duo called click
who leaked so i will use frequently this
name click udeek so to describe this
couple Janice work accounts of your
colleague and this is one of the site
projections we are showing at our
exhibition it is called variations of
red and the way of edward gierek can we
can we play it because this steel
but so this is another reason to visit
gallery after my my speech okay so
typically the talented students of
Wisconsin and the Academy of Fine Arts
in Warsaw where the first artists to
conceive a radical political turn to
Hansen's theory of the open forum since
the beginning of the 70s licklick
pioneered the transformation of artistic
practice into one of social
experimentation more laboratory than
studio creating artistic groups that
promoted values and models of non
authoritarian social system click click
as candidates the communist party at the
beginning of the 70s postulated
connecting politics and art they wanted
politicians to be as creative as artists
and artists to be as committed to
transforming reality as politicians and
this slide shows was meant to stress
that this these common goals licklick
used they try to use their kind of sub
dash subversive revisionist position
within the system to sue severely
criticized baggage Communist Party and
the party which had swept
internationalism for nationalism in the
60s and try to combine socialism with
consumerism and elements of capitalism
in the early seventies both communism
administration's go mochas in the
sixties and garrick in the seventies try
in this hybrid manner to legitimize the
authoritarian system in Poland according
to critic who wanted to be faithful to
the true of social distribution
revolutionary idea such cynical
killed the emancipatory universalistic
potential of socialism give you get now
buying nationalism and consumerism quick
licks reformist practices were centered
around attempts to introduce new more
flexible and interdisciplinary
mechanisms to the socialist States
existing procedures whether in politics
are in the field of cultural policy let
us add that those attempts were based on
the conclusions drawn not only from
revolutionary artistic ideas has an open
forum in particular but also from the
progress being made in science
especially they were kind of observe
observing the developments of
cybernetics they also established
cybernetics like artistic associations
artistic division of the Polish
cybernetic Association and the regime
however rejected the offer preferring to
exploit those innovations and
discoveries for the purpose of
strengthening its own apparatus of
bureaucratic control while creating an
appearance of liberalisation and a
greater openness towards the rest of the
world prefer to use them to modernize
the constantly growing centralized state
administration that tried to control
almost every aspect of citizens lives
click Oleg and other revisionists with
the proposal of not
scientific self-organizing open systems
of communication knowledge production or
management were rejected the year idea
that new discoveries of science and art
should be put to work towards the goal
of non authoritarian and truly
democratic socialist state in which
individual and collective emancipation
is possible was destroyed trying to
intensify the revolutionary process they
were defeated by a process that Antonio
negra described as a consolidation of
socialism very characteristic for the
Soviet bloc States at the turn of the
60s and 70s negra you wrote the problem
is that at certain point in the
consolidation of socialism defeated the
revolutionary process holding back
blocking that threshold of social and
political movement that was born from
the struggle against power against
exploitation consolidating itself
socialism achieved enormous results in
the first place it demonstrated that it
was possible in the second place it
imposed on the bourgeois economy a
radical modification but in its
consolidation was also betrayal
corruption in the place of generation
bureaucratization of power instead of
its liberation in a great argues that as
a result of its consolidation and
bureaucratization socialism killed
itself committed suicide but my
colleague
working in such conditions described by
an angry in our auto pian manner try to
speed up our revolutionary process they
permanently problematize the distinction
imposed and strictly observed by the
regime between the public and the
private trying to redefine the relations
between the these two spheres
considering them in terms of
interpenetration they are being common
rather than in terms of binary opposites
they did so in the artistic collectives
deformed and in the integral integrative
games and directions that were based on
initiating open-ended a spontaneous
processes of communication describing
that period krekula crowd we believed in
the possibility of smooth collaboration
with other artists in the possibility of
collective work free from the problem of
authorship from war is over what is
pools and who did what an artist should
be free and unselfish and the new should
be generated at the meeting point of me
and the others in interaction the corec
believed they acted politically by
creating areas that blurred the borders
between individual and between
individual creative gestures and there's
their son forming an emergent collective
work in this they seem to be creating
something in the vein of the common the
common capacity to produce and reproduce
the social in freedom according to negri
when you speak of common you don't think
of the public but of something that
isn't either private or public
the real socialism which Pakula composed
in the seventies Poland confuse the
common with the public that is reduced
it to the property of the state the
project of my colleague of the common
consisted instead in overcoming both the
concept of the private and that of the
public in going beyond those two
categories to arrive at communal
management and coating can agree it is
everyone together and this is not out of
young following the rejection by the
regime of critics offer the artists
continued their dire efforts to
undermine the state imposed distinction
between the public and the private they
try to overcome the states and the
parties manipur monopoly for managing
the common good or rather for defining
common values as something completely
separate from private life because
communist regime never imagined the
common if not just like the capitalists
as something that is appropriated into
conclusion the Polish Communist part the
rejection of critics reform proposals
and the subsequent launch of a secret
police require into their activities
reveals one more aspect of the conflict
between the doer artistic political
investigations and departing the prague
spring of nineteen sixty eight
demonstrated that a revolution carried
out by revisionists that is from within
the communist system could be far more
dangerous than any ideological
aggression from outside in 1970s
capitalist poland fickle acquired class
example of risk on subversion through
identification proving that the dominant
ideology could be undermined by a too
literal identification with it because
it's successful functioning requires a
minimal distance from its exploited
roles that is why the reform is cyclic
trying to realize socialist ideas into
pretty literal fashion were treated
particularly harshly by the regime we
which did not identify it with those
ideas at all they were verified for the
true / socialist idea in a socialist
country where now I'm deleting this in
it except them ended in almost complete
isolation in exclusion from both
politics dominated by cynicism and from
contemporary art dominated by pragmatic
escapism so thank you
oh I'm going to talk about the American
and European context for what's being
discussed so far excuse me if I could
have the first slide do I do that we do
you do that thank you this is jonas
mekas of course and i want to just throw
out it through a few ideas for
discussion later said this is not in any
way any kind of academic academically
formed thesis or anything like that but
it just struck me as very interesting
that at the same time as these open
forum experiments were taking place in
Warsaw that there was a lot of
collectivity going on throughout USA and
also in Europe especially in England in
fact and how how differently it plays
out in a communist country like Poland
and then here in the USA with whether
it's some collective activity like woman
house in LA the conceptual art museum
the factory anthology film archives or
in England the arts lab in London
filmmakers co-ops in New York and London
exploding galaxies in London of David
Madonna the artist placement group with
Jonathan Stewart brisley and all those
artists with it with invasive capitalist
environment in that case but in
environment which was undergoing greater
economic depression at the time so I
begin with this image of jonas mekas
because Jonah Sousa course from
Lithuania and so we have probably the
most influential figure in cinema
experimental cinema in New York coming
from not so far from Poland which i
think is an interesting thing to note
and the jonassen and the anthology film
archives space that he established at 80
was the street in soho where so many
artists lived at the time really created
this raise of collective space which had
a big impact on artists everybody you
could think of who was living there who
came and saw films there but not only
films also performances expanded cinema
pieces video works etc and of course
Jonas was very close to George mikunis a
fellow Lithuanian and his collectivity
which was inspired by Russian
revolutionary ideas was was very radical
it not only did it form all the flux
houses in Soho George machinist probably
gave his life for that in the end he got
beaten up so many times by the mob when
he was establishing those flux houses
for the artists to live in I think there
were how many were there 18 in the end
buildings many artists still live in
them today from that period but also
this has a collectivity that was at the
basis of fluxes and you know I feel that
Jonas's presence is very is very
important in relation to this American
context now cause Warhol's factory which
I'm not going to really discuss but just
mention as another form of collectivity
of course it revolved around the persona
of war himself but most collectives
ultimately in my opinion do usually men
and the backdrop in America of course
was Vietnam and I cannot emphasize
enough in my opinion how important
Vietnam was to the American situation
here and the way in which artists were
were thinking at the time here's an
illustration of that moment with her
Lester's film one week in Vietnam made
in 1970 which is color photographs of
all from Life magazine of all the
American soldiers killed in Vietnam in
one week with their numbers flicking by
as the photos click x on the left to the
soundtrack of the audibility brothers
bye-bye love but perhaps one of the most
obvious comparisons that could be made
is in television because of course
nowhere but in the states could have we
seen American and we still see it in
television playing such a role such a
major role in politics and influencing
people
such an extreme degree and this image on
the screen is of an issue of radical
software volume 2 number thank you
number 2 and radical software was
started by belcaro Phyllis gershmi and
Irish Schneider and it first appeared in
spring of nineteen seventy just not so
long after a low-cost portable video
equipment became available to artists
and in the first issue it stated power
is no longer measured in land labour or
capital but by access to information and
the means to disseminate it that was in
issue number one and David Ross has a
wonderful website with radical software
and every single issue is online you can
read it and David Ross's introduction is
well worth reading and he he talks about
the genesis of radical software in a way
that I think really has a very
interesting relationship to this open
forum principle the idea for the journal
came about in the fall and I'm quoting
David of 1969 right after the Woodstock
Festival the Vietnam War was raging a
previously powerless and voiceless
generation in the US and abroad found
that they could no longer trust their
governments or the newspapers and
television networks to communicate any
truth except those in the service of the
prevailing order and so the urge to
create new cultural structures was a
genuine attempt to help need a
generation out of the wasteland in which
many felt entrapped this assortment of
artists writers musicians and filmmakers
shared a vision they imagined a social
order in which new forms of community
might be formed and maintained by the
development of an interlocking network
of shared intelligence or what Jean
Youngblood called of videos fear I think
Jean lung bugs idea is videos very very
interesting they imagine a world in
which the contest of ideas and values
could excuse me take place freely and
openly outside the outside of the
existing institutional framework and in
active opposition to the world view
constructed and maintained by broadcast
commercial TV they propose not only a
reordered power structure but also a new
information order in which the very idea
of hierarchical power structure might be
transformed or even eliminate
for them radical software would provide
a platform for the exploration of
alternatives to the dominant mass media
structure and would do so in a matter
that in a manner that mixed the
subjective style of the New Journalism
with a non precious self-published
format of the whole earth catalog so
radical software as a journal really I
think epitomized a mood that was
prevailing in America at the beginning
of the 70s at the time say at the same
time that these experiments were that
were taking place in Warsaw and what's
on the screen now is ant farms medium
media burn from 1975 and action by a
collective in San Francisco called ant
farm who just as astronauts drove it's
reconstructed El Dorado 1959 cadillac
convertible through a flaming wall of
flaming TV sets and you can see how
dramatic it looks and they they used
these obviously these very obvious to
cultural icons of the America the car
the television set to really question
the holes are American American heroic
ideal and sort of technological
superiority if you like and they also
style the the action after the news
coverage of a space launch so they
included various of melodramatic
interviews with journalists who had
gathered there and Doug Hall played John
a John F Kennedy who was giving a speech
to journalists about the problem of the
mass mass media monopolies our impact on
American life so you can see that
television was very much at the center
of what many American artists were
thinking and likewise some WGBH
commissioned artists and so there was a
very odd situation where artists were
railing against television and
television was itself was momentarily
opening up and so WGBH was commissioning
artists like Nam June Paik can see his
global groove is an image from global
groov up here to make works for
television this was also
case with the deluxe II foundation on
KQED TV over in san francisco and the de
lexi foundation brought together a group
of artists including walter de maria to
make a series of pieces for television
this is still from walter de Rais
hardcore from 1969 the film that he made
for television and the idea was that it
would be it would be broadcast on
television which it was so there was
this very interesting moment which is
also occurring in England and this is
David Hall a very very important British
video artist it's astonishing known in
America and New York's shown him yet I
hope they will who made a piece called
television interruptions in 1973
commissioned by Scottish television who
in another unprecedented Lee Auckland
moment in British television
commissioned a group of artists
including David to make these inserts
into television programs during the
evening so there was nothing to say they
were going to appear and as David said
these transmissions were a surprise a
mystery no explanations reactions were
various I viewed one piece in an old
gents club in Edinburgh the TV was
permanently on but the occupants were
oblivious to it reading newspapers or
dozing when the TV began to fill with
water newspapers dropped the dozing
stopped when the piece finished normal
activity was resumed and as you can see
in this still as you can imagine what
happened was suddenly EastEnders or
whatever was on at the time crossroads
aircars was interrupted by the
television screens suddenly appearing as
though a tank and a tap turned on water
and then suddenly the the screen filled
up as though it was a tank filling with
water so you can see just so both that
this was going on this is questioning
around television as a dominant form of
control this was being questioned by
artists on both sides of the Atlantic in
England and
and in states now in relation to
architecture to bring it back to
architecture for a moment we also have
the studio asserting itself in the work
of artists so in terms of physical space
one could say that the the white cube of
the gallery or the studio although the
studio Dan never never tends to be quite
as white and Pristina the gallery but
the white cube in the most general sense
was if you like almost a kind of e to
pull parent against which artists were
flinging themselves and this piece very
well known of course to assault by bruce
nauman walking an exaggerated manner
around the perimeter of a square shows
now man walking around the studio he's
got masking tape masking off the the
floor and he shifts his hips very
exaggeratedly at every step in this very
sort of game-like movements that are
very monotonous and he just gets round
and round and round clearly influenced
both by samuel beckett and also by the
dancer Anna Halprin who herself was
making a very sore open systems kind of
radical dance using the local community
as well as dancers and this this
questioning of the artwork by as an
object by creating something that was an
action in the studio that nobody could
see that then was captured on videotape
his part of a sort of decentering and I
sort of pulling a part of the both
physical space of the gallery and the
physical presence of the object Richard
Serra was also doing the same thing in
this film hands scraping you can see him
with Phil glasses various sculpture
sculptor like forearms on the left field
glasses forearms on the right and that
they scrape very carefully a number of
steel shavings off the floor of the
studio in this very task-based
performative action that became very of
typical of this as a post minimalist
activity of the sort of D deconstruction
of the object they very they very
carefully pick up the very last iron
filing or still shaving I should say
in what would normally be seen as a very
unimportant action could be much more
efficiently achieved by the brisk sweep
of a broom and and so that the
positioning of this metal debris of an
unseen supposedly sculptural objects
somewhere at the artist the artist hand
and body the studio floor and the d'etre
has become the central subject of the
film so this is turning away of the
object and replacing it by by the by an
action and then of course we have
another a sort of architectural not in
the studio in this case but
architectural questioning of the object
through in this case slides in down
groans project for slide projector and
and Dan said and I quote the carousel
slide projector becomes an object the
message to be the mechanism of the
medium in itself as an object and
basically what Dan did was he took four
small panes of glass and he made a box
with a mirror in the bottom and he
photographed all four sides and then
photographed them again getting closer
and closer to the middle point and then
put another box inside and photograph
that and then another and then another
until you have the box and the other box
and the other box all photographed 20
times he then flipped as the slides
backwards so that you get basically two
lots of a 40 slide so he builds and
unbilled this object and so during the
projection of all the 80 images the
spatial ambiguity of the mirror space
moves cyclically and it sort of inverts
itself so it builds and unveil so we're
seeing a piece that's located somewhere
between the materials and experiences of
sculpture and photography but it's but
it's not essential to either so it
captures the experience almost of
walking around a sculpture and the
spectators perception becomes
the key the key to the piece so it's
also an image of the experience of
looking at sculpture so here we have
this sort of decentering of the object
this this this collapsing of the central
authority of the object which Bob Morris
in a piece like come neoclassic in 1971
does to Bob Morris made a very important
show at the Tate in London in 1971 in
which he built a series of objects which
i think is very interesting in relation
to the open forum experiments and in
these objects which were made of wood
the visitors to the exhibition had to
engage with the objects they could roll
around on them move around on top of
them put them on top of themselves do
whatever they wanted to them they the
objects became objects with which the
audience could play eventually the the
tape was so disturbed by the fact that
people getting injured by their
enthusiastic engagement with the objects
that they they took the objects away
close down the show and insisted that
Bob Morris replaced these objects with
some more conventional sculptures so
what Morris did was he made a film
called neo classic in which a figure
engages with these objects so that the
the record of it was was was there in
perpetuity but the film also became
another artwork in itself so again you
see this sort of decentering and the way
in which also someone like dennis
Oppenheim with this full screen film
installation echo from 1973 takes the
artists hand and takes the paintbrush
away takes the canvas takes anything but
the hand and the wall and slaps the hand
against the wall in four projections
this has a kind of contrapuntal oral
composition which seems to be breaking
that has a feeling of breaking down the
architectural space so you have almost a
literal sense of this the artist trying
to trying to kind of destroy the
architectural space boundary
and again dennis Oppenheim two-stage
transfer drawing retreating to a past
state and of this piece again very
interesting relation to the idea of both
play and at the game and also at the
root the role of video and the body the
body is material and the wall as site
and in this piece dennis Oppenheim son
draws a pattern on Dennis often hands
back and then it's oppenheim tries to
draw the same pattern on the wall what
he imagines his son is drawing is very
interesting relationship too there's a
closed closed circuit systems a video
there but also again perception the
perception of the D the D
contextualizing of the idea of the the
wall as the space for painting and by
implication drawing we also have
architectural space and painting being
questioned in the work of Paul McCarthy
in his performative videotapes of the
early 70s in this one he's he's drawing
a line on the floor with paint we have
now Minh applying the makeup to himself
in art makeup because the sense of the
mask for the importance of the mask and
in fact this piece relates to his word
cakes the consummate mask of rock where
he said this is my mask of fidelity to
truth and life this is to cover the mask
of pain and desire the need for human
companionship this is to mask the cover
this is to cover the masker this is the
need of cover this is the need of the
mask so again we have this masking this
sense of of play as we do in Joan
Jonas's left side right side where Joan
takes the screen and splits it and says
this is my right eye but because one is
mirrored it's very very difficult to
follow her and for her to follow herself
and everybody gets very confused so just
to finish I want to just mention the
importance of the camera for women in
the 70s because this and the idea of the
open system the open structure women
took up the video camera as we know
precisely because it had no history so
as a certain kind of political acts
a personal political act to redefine the
way in which women were depicted on the
TV screen by the media and we see an
artist like Hannah Wilkie with gestures
her video from 1974 some of the gestures
that she pulls her face into seem
comical that the others are rather
tragic they distort her face into into
expressions that she absolutely that
people would not find attractive
likewise marina abramovic errs art must
be beautiful artist must be beautiful in
video in which she takes two hairbrushes
and and she's in communist yugoslavia at
the time of tito communism so very
different communism to that of warsaw
that communism nevertheless and the
social body has such a different reading
there and so still in communist
yugoslavia in belgrade she takes to hair
brushes and pulls them not through only
through her hair but across her face
reciting art most beautiful artist must
be beautiful damaging her face damaging
her skin and trying to make a sort of
defiant gesture against the dichotomy of
the depiction of female beauty and
painting versus the impossibility of the
female to be if she's a good looking in
the remotest way I've taken seriously at
all as an artist and at the same time
someone like all I before he met
Abramovich was making very androgynous
actions videotapes and photographs where
he was again in Germany trying to sort
of under undermine that male male figure
at the end of the war or after the war
by by going into a very and regina's
transvestite state so all these I have a
few more but I'm going to end there
because I think I've probably gone on
too long all these i'm just going to
actually fast forward to to to this
piece by antony mccall because i think
it's also relevant to
yayuh I open forum which is called
circulation figures which is a piece not
so known by Anthony but it's it was made
in London just before he came to New
York and in it he got a space and placed
a mirror at the back and strew the floor
with paper and got together a group of
artists friends and filmmakers who
brought cameras of film cameras and
still cameras and photographed each
other so they moved around the space
photographing each other photographing
each other and so again this very kind
of game like quality this this this very
sort of playful way in which these
gestures were then and there's a film
that records everybody making all the
different actions with each other but
what what what underlines all these very
playful actions I think it's something
that has a very interesting resonance to
the open forum experiments that we see
in the exhibition next door and I think
you'll be very interesting to tease out
some of the issues related to both the
similarities and the differences
hi there you know I don't have any
images so maybe it's a good idea to turn
on the lights because I see people are
getting very sleepy so I think I was
invited here to speak maybe because I
stand a little bit of time in wood and
wood and which film academy it was
actually parallel in the second very
very important center for experimental
film and this type of production in
Poland in the 70s I was there for a
rather lengthy period of time in 2004
and during which i actually had
incredible opportunity to meet a large
group of artists from the workshop group
which was very active in the late
sixties early seventies Belinda Academy
it was a self-organized group of
filmmakers and after this visit I
continued a relationship with Joseph
Arabic offski one of the key figures
within this group and in 2005 I
commissioned him to write the text for a
publication I was working with with
Manifesta foundation on on the topic of
experimental art education Joseph did
write the text unfortunately the text
wasn't a completely different subject so
we never published it but the text is
very very interesting particularly in
relationship to this discussion and
maybe this exhibition so i think what i
will do is kind of publish it by perhaps
reading it to you there are a couple of
disclaimers here first of all it
contains a lot of polish names that
aren't just impossible for me to
pronounce so each time when I come to a
very long list of names because Joseph
tries to acknowledge and thank a lot of
his collaborators of the period I will
not be able to do it I will try to
publish this text in an edited version
sometime
fall in if lecture and also you'll have
an opportunity to read it correctly then
and I've never read it in public before
so I really don't know how long it takes
it's about seven pages and I will try to
read it quickly so it's not to go over
the time limit so in that case I will
start right now it has a very romantic
title it's called the power of art and
perhaps that relates to this pragmatist
escape is Mukesh was referring to in his
presentation so how does one find enough
stamina to defend one's convictions this
principle question of the late 1950s and
early 1960s was the point of departure
for our progressive movement it had its
roots in the University of Thorin ended
it was a harbinger of freedom in the
pseudo humanitarian Polish People's
Republic I belong to the family of a
disowned landowner and I had a chance to
observe since childhood becoming his
destruction of my fatherland and my
family heirloom as a war child I was a
staunch anti-communist my generation
made the first country cynical gestures
against the communist authorities in
1956 when we marched in the streets of
Turin in a spontaneous forum
demonstration shouting anti-government
slogans in the huge crowd I realized as
did many of my colleagues that it would
be possible for a well-organized group
to set up some kind of a free
progressive artistic movement not
conforming to the authorities of
people's Poland in the second half of
1950s polish culture experienced an
enormous growth still under EGIS of
socialist slogan of a better world free
from violence this new unique artistic
consciousness manifested itself in
literature poetry music cinema theatre
and plastic arts it began to ready it
outside of Poland and the new contacts
with the artists from abroad burst the
earlier provincial and listless
socialist culture sponsored by the party
in 1958 I took an an entrance exam to
the woods our film school which was a
special place at the time and no aces of
free artistic thought I failed but on
that occasion i visited the art museum
in which which display works of Katerina
Carol Hill the healer that was the
modern tradition which had raised polish
art to world a class level studying the
works of such artists we were later to
formulate our independent analytical
program which found expressions in
activities of the woodwork shop of film
forum in the 1960s I began studying at
the fine art department of the
university of turin i specialized in
museum management and art history it was
a very productive time I got involved
with many in tradition interdisciplinary
groups such as ok 0 0 61 Hitler Kruk and
thanks to our professors who managed to
distance ourselves from their official
cultural policies most of these
professors have come to torrent from the
Vilnius University disbanded after World
War Two their absolute independence from
the reigning ideology was a model for
their students the metaphorical large
format photographs created by the
members of the student amateur art group
0 61 were dismissed by the official
critics as anachronistic well in fact
they impressed the public with their
modern form and artistic standard today
this play attic for regrets from the 60s
are regarded by Polish art historians as
pioneering postmodern works since they
were motivated by historical awareness
in his new expressive symbolic sense
even then we already realized that our
artistic productions had to be promoted
outside the official distribution
channels we showed our photographic
works and films at the reviews and the
reviews were reorganized in 1960s we
mounted the photographic shows of 0 61
group in specially adapted venues rather
than the official salons managed by the
office of art exhibitions they usually
took form of the announced unannounced
monetary interventions in into the open
public space all of those experience of
the 0-60 one group and the creative
students film club pitler came handy
when I set out together with my
colleagues
activate them in wood where I had
finally came to study in 1966 at the
film school school having graduated from
the tauren University in the next two
years more taruni ins came to hooch
including and here there is a very very
long list of names our ideas were them
taking in the late 1960s by other
students and graduates of the film
school such as a voice a Brzezinski
today was jus neck bikini free/busy
Bible via who was mentioned earlier
several times Richard washko casimir
burner kofsky marico turski Richard
nevsky etc etc in 1970 as a student's
academic circle performed a research
creative group the workshop of film
forum totally independent from the
official didactic program the first
manifest of this group stated the
workshop came into being in 1970s on the
initiative of a group of students and
graduates of the wood school of film
television and theatre besides
filmmakers it includes artists musicians
photographers poets and technicians the
workshop makes films recordings TV
broadcast radio programmes art
exhibitions various art events and
interventions the workshop also engages
in theoretical research and critical
study it explores and expands the
potential of audiovisual arts note that
the workshop does not engage in any
commercial activity and his participants
work absolutely disinterestedly
originally the creative method and
techniques of the workshop owed much to
a professor a bullish loffley we ask
ahead of the Fire Department of theory
and history of film in his eccentric
lively class in the film school 1960s we
analyzed various techniques of montage
preparing their graphics course on paper
it was Professor Lee whiskey who since
nineteen sixty-six provided us with
classical and current reading material
which became the basis for the
development of a broad range of ideas in
film and photography it was thanks to
him that we got acquainted with the
writings of Elisha Heldman cloud Levi
Strauss room
yups Jacobson Edgar Morin Adam chef
marshall mcluhan roland burris Christian
mats and others published in Poland in
nineteen not not published in Poland
Andre basins book published in Poland in
1963 film and reality was our set rating
and the chapter the anthology and
language from the book we came to now
particularly well its fragments were
cited by vers la Rosa ski in the
catalogue of Thorin exhibition in 1969
however we were more interested in ideas
of Bisons followers are rollin Barden
Christian meds we discovered very early
in this books from 1950s and 1960s
researchers regarded photography as a
form of reality in the words of the
American avant-garde filmmaker from the
1940s maya deren in photography the
object creates its own image by
radiating it slide onto a photosensitive
film no human participates in this
process this is the source of the
realism of a photographic image this
materialistic view adopted by and
reversing was relative was relativized
in 1960s by bar submits there are new
attitude towards photographic reality
was taken out by the loop by the late
1960s by the future members of the
workshop Bob Elliott even carried out
some research on this issue with the
participants of the action workshop at
the Art Museum of woods in 1973 the
relationship between the subjective and
the objective was the principal issue
was set out to investigate in the
beginning of the 1970s both in our
writings and in our works were found a
kindred soul in completely
unpronounceable name I'm sorry from
worse who well versed in theory in 1971
we entered into close cooperation with
him invited him to participate in many
events that we instigated at that time
at the time of who won second individual
initiatives led us to develop since
1970s new personal contacts with
outstanding artists our partners abroad
included malcolm lee Brice Richard
DeMarco William and Birgit hen jrg
Klaus Burke doc Akiko lamora Peter Bible
Valley expert al becca William rabanne
bullsh artists David Curtis p Ruben Dora
Maurer Gabor body Marina Abramovic vulaj
florists new sous and many others whom
it is impossible to mention here we also
learn more about art and culture thanks
to the books from the Italian center d
which we obtained in exchange for our
theoretical publications the whole
complicated arrangement of international
contacts was made possible thanks to the
post art project post art project which
we developed in the early 1970s all the
above shows that our generation Orient
that our general orientation was
composed of many threats while and
really reading this very badly I'm sorry
the workshop was an open project its
main aim being interpersonal
communication and exchange of ideas our
private contacts enabled us to pee pee
on the communist curtain and post art
gave us a chance of explicating the
ideas contained in our works documents
photographs text films and video films
it is worth mentioning here that the
analytical rational Pratt bout practices
that appeared in our works already in
1960s they had particularly many
followers of in multimedia arts
association called group circle my first
films which I presented at my exam to
the
school in 1958-59 called philippe feet
siii mini painterly Luxa grams carmen
labyrinth forest my trick photographs
drunkard of 1959 and above all my first
photographic objects trainer of nineteen
sixty our neo data works our films from
1962 and my personal constructed
collages used found footage which was
quite unique in 1962 our other important
works from that time included burleson
synthetic photographs of via Slav would
ruin Lani's which were I came to
American photography eg work of Edwards
Western a limited offer health cabbage
another important project of analytical
rational character involved the
so-called references which first
appeared in my work entitled blacksmith
of 1962 presenting a portrait of a
blacksmith from the small town inserted
into a big photograph of a toil war in
hand this work is now in a collection of
the regional museum interim more of the
references turned up later in a large
University exhibition of the 0-60 one
group mounted in the yard of Collegium
unison probe it was then that we
juxtapose our worked with the elements
of the environment in open space this
precursor irrational gesture was noted
by two worse reviewers of the exhibition
there I described this project in my
report of development in the book the
decade 1980s 1990s I also discuss it in
my in several essays Polar's by santram
snooki the references turn up once again
in 1966 in another form of multimedia
exhibition event of the Krug Association
where we check support various natural
curiosities a two-headed calf stuffed
birds human and animal skeletons an
enormous vertebra of a whale which we
had word from the department the first
scientists of our works displayed in a
plurality
other neo data works were presented at
the second exhibition of Krug at the
regional museum in turin in 1977 the
artists most in evidence there was the
fictional character joseph kabila who
showed the objects antidote lady with a
necklace and epitaph for john young not
and by stitches of perfectly executed
academic works in the style topical of
our professors the photographs by George
Jersey Isaac and Andre sorry can't
pronounce last name consisting of
rhythmical arrangements of pre-war
postcard set to the old song but would
this world be without love gravitated
towards a surreal other authors of
collages and film but later include
antoni Miko Miko and Luke & M Cocotte
such critical ironic or sarcastic
attitude is characteristic of many works
created by the member of 0 61 group
since its inception in 1967 before even
before the subjective exhibition in
Krakov I became particularly interested
in the problem of duality in HX the
position of the real world with an
illusory one in mirror reflections
various interactive objects films and
trick photographs I was making at the
film school this interest culminated in
a large size photograph object bicycle
wheel from 1969 at at illogical work I
jack suppose a real wide bicycle wheel
looks a graphic image of that object my
stance was also manifested in other
photographs such as ten fields of acuity
four fields of acuity both from 1969 the
first film of the workshop entitled the
market made by my colleagues today or
tunic and are Masoner in 1970 in the red
market in wood and other spatial object
ear by purchase love Rajev ski from 1971
shown at the exhibition of the searching
photographers at the worst of
contemporary gallery which also were of
analytical character similar attempts
were made by antoni me
nicosia and by belk we are in the late
1960s even before the establishment of
the workshop we had discovered in the
class of film animation conducted by
professor kotovsky the brikar the
precursors of analytical photographic
sequences we were most fascinated by
Edward may bridge t atkinson Etienne
jos mara and nate allen futurists the
style and content of their works were
explored most bios magnifica whose
graphic style and complex fuel
realizations were later universally
admired another personality in the
workshop was its youngest member Pebble
Creek who began cooperating as a camera
operator with the students of Warsaw
academy of fine arts the steam
elaborated the spatial concept of
Professor Oscar Hansen it included and
then there is a very long list of names
including Sofia kulick the films they
made together analyzing the interesting
idea of the open forum were presented at
which film school during the meeting of
the eighth cinema in 1971 and a year
later at zakopane at the review of films
on art in early 1970s the early 1970s
brought an unprecedented eruption and
creative activity of the students and
graduates of art academies manifested in
nova ruda we're in 1971 we met zhang
yong with a very complicated name
inviting him immediately to which we
began traveling with our films and set
of and sets of photographs too many
Polish galleries we visited several
cities crack of were soaked dansk Lublin
bosna Thorin and finally organized a
large self sponsored international
review of expanded cinema entitled Kino
laboratory in 1973 at gallery al our
project oz makino the eighth cinema was
intended to counterbalance the third
cinema a group of young filmmakers
pampered by the critics laureates of the
official state festivals include such as
christophe kozlowski we have supported
among the editors of krakow
magazine students we have supporters
among the critics years where we managed
to publish and two interventionist text
our statement written collectively and
my Lampoon and cinematography so we can
actually go a little bit further
okay we were decidedly against
operations on reality in the romantic
style of the dash counter our works
entered the natural in urban environment
meaning during the event entitled
furniture sale in 1971 in the red market
in which on on an autumn morning we
asked an amateur artist to sell out the
various pieces of furniture and I had
inherited from my aunt at absurdly low
prices a large stand before he drops
mirrors sofas and old books were
surrounded by standards and buyers at
noon the seller vanished after a few
minutes it turned out that everything
that had belonged to my aunt was gone
the only object left was an old sofa set
on fire by some hooligans were observed
people of the reactions and talked to
them were interested in our
interlocutors the event let us revise
our mental schemas and preconceptions at
another occasion we've also left the
field to other people instigating a
collective declamation word by word by
randomly approached passer by's of the
poem ode to youth by polish national
poet adam akatsuki in piotrowska street
the main street of wood during the
action workshop at the which art museum
we conducted perhaps the first art TV
broadcast in the world from several
sites in the city which transmitted 3 TV
images with sound effects with the aid
of schools mobile broadcasting unit for
12 hours from a private flat at a
carpenter shop and a busy intersection
to a room at the museum we also called a
competition for an artistic signature
which enjoyed enormous interest the work
sent into the competition were shown at
the Art Museum and we gave valuable book
awards to the winners at another time by
will quake encouraged schoolchildren and
several provincial towns near wood to
create few mateusz the whole group
performed in various cities with Edward
Kowalski theatre of pensioners we became
his devout followers performing his play
entitled the career and death of adult
they're at a school theatre and at the
art museum during the action workshop
even mentioned here in 1974 we made a
film entitled reincarnation as an Amish
terror professor unstuck thanks to our
occur cooperation with many artists
laughing formal education and technical
expertise when minish many times to
enter in new creative territories which
was the source of great artistic
satisfaction seeking to educate
ourselves we're organizing me illogical
symposiums and conferences at the film
school we published our theoretical
writings and analyzed mini archival
fields of the first avant-garde in
France Germany and Russia we started
montage devices and tricks and films
made by members of the Soviets kool
cigarette off sergei eisenstein pudovkin
we traveled to were so to see the
performances at Jerzy Grotowski theater
we discovered in the archive the only
preserved pre-war film made by francesca
and steph at emerson the adventures of
an honest man from 1937 which was
presented at the international review
keno laboratorium so maybe we're almost
there is a few more name lists what's
quite interesting we presented our
attitude for discussion of the film
schools in Moscow and German Democratic
Republic maintained systematic contacts
of Hungarian filmmakers and as a result
made a new new interesting contacts with
other young filmmakers of the so-called
communist bloc finally the workshop of
film forum was discovered by the owner
of an Edinburgh gallery Richard DeMarco
during his stay in which he invited us
to the Edinburgh film festival as
members of the large polish project
called italia 72 there for the first
time i had a chance to present our works
along the works of outstanding polish in
for an avant-garde at the invitation of
curators and artists who visited many
Western European cities such as antwerp
amsterdam Council London Paris Cologne
Dusseldorf
venice etc but we also showed our works
in moscow prague budapest belgrade the
enormous artistic output of our
multimedia group was presented for the
first time at the monographic exhibition
of the workshop of film forum at the
Center for Contemporary Art and worsened
in the year 2000 the exhibition several
huge rooms at the seca were filled with
the works of different character mostly
film projections photograph spatial
installations interactive objects TV
documents and broadcast and visual text
an accompanying exhibition displayed
booklets he needs publications posters
for a graphic documentation today the
workshop has its own monographs written
by Richard closets see Lucas rotunda and
Joseph Rebecca ski film made the films
made by the groups are distributed in
Poland and abroad evoking ever ever
bigger interest after 40 years of this
fervent activity I often ask myself how
is it all possible in the provincial
Poland instant enslaved by communist
ideology enforced and asked by the
Soviet regime but I am convinced today
that we owe it to the power of art and
art appears and capital letters which we
always regard as a heaven of freedom it
was for us an article of faith that an
artist can influence the shape of
reality armed with the belief that
someone still needs him that's it
so I think Anton has proven that seven
minutes of text does not equal five
minutes but come up here please so we're
going to just quickly turn to some some
questions since we're running behind and
we'd like to get to the gallery scene to
see the opening so I just thought I'd
open it up to the audience to see if
anybody has any specific questions for
any of the speakers or any anticipatory
questions about the exhibition which
we're about to see
you mean the book from 2005 open book
it's exactly the same words and actually
comes so I wonder
but as Felicity presented open for my
house and we see that was really
symbolic I was translated into polish
quite thoroughly but this concept of
open almost as chrissy also described
the American situation was in the air
let's say in the 60s and in art and
literature so it was not a direct
relation between a combo and this
activities we are showing at the
exhibition so apparently no relationship
anything else I'm just going to pose a
couple of very quick questions n because
we do want to run out of the gallery the
first time going to post a Felicity in
it around this question of the
processional and participatory practice
have informed because we know what the
participants declared their obsession
with cybernetics it declared their
obsessions with communications theory
and they to the point that they enacted
themselves is almost like cybernetic
agents as you showed in the film and I'm
wondering about that relationship in
which open form becomes a type of
process a literal ization of
communication theory let's say and
something like Hansen's electronic
projects in the exhibition we show the
electronic music studio and you show the
scope your project in which there's an
idea about the building itself
transforming through an electronic
effect and this might be a lot to ask
but I'm just wondering if you've had if
you've thought about how what the
relationship is between something like
cybernetics as a paradigm for collective
interaction versus something like a
building as a cyber net
mechanism and how that might work for
Henson's open forum no I haven't thought
about the precise articulation that you
suggest but suddenly I was trying to
raise the question even if somewhat
laterally of if we think about the
degree to which some of these ideals of
electronic spaces you know later came to
be understood as really haunted by
technologies of control that they reveal
themselves not only to require another
set of a sort of functional determinate
I was trying it I guess at some point to
put a little bit of pressure on how that
my also be thought of in regard to their
quite utopian thinking about electronics
but but the work I mean 11 project that
I hope people will go and pay some
attention to which i think is a
fantastic film is the project in the
studios at 123 yeah whether the the
artist is asking each of the camera
operators to shoot him in a particular
way and he's saying you know so now we
turn to camera one yeah now we current
camera two and and and this is a film
that was shown on television actually
come back to Chrissy's suggestion and
it's a film that in effect shows the or
or reveals the constructive nature of
the image yeah for the television
audience and I think that but also a
number of the other films had a similar
I know this doesn't speak exactly to
what you're asking but there was a sense
of a sort of incredibles of
consciousness and attention to exactly
how this media image was being
constructed
disseminated yes that I think is maybe
lacking and something like this coffee
project and I yes so so to that degree i
think the you know not only does this
sort of dialogue go both ways but the
sort of lessons the sort of
attentiveness that the architects might
might take back from the artist and the
way they deploy the the concept of open
forum and and and sort of translated it
into a different set of tactic may
indeed sort of need to fold back further
into the architectural context no that
doesn't answer your question exactly but
it's sort of how i was trying to stage
those that's very helpful um I'm going
to ask one cash one last question before
we head over to me it's a slightly
related question which is that if the
music studio versus open forum as as a
kind of interactivity is at question
your phrase that the artists were trying
to accelerate the revolution seems you
know an incredibly compelling way to
describe the activity but of course that
begs the question of what kind of
revolution they were trying to
accelerate and and and when you think
about the type of revolutionary
practices that Chrissy was describing
which are revolutionary in terms of
their application of new media
technologies revolutionary and if we're
going to use that term loosely in
relationship to status of objects etc
you clearly need something else you mean
much more explicit political program
nonetheless what I'm interested in is
what becomes of objects within that
notion of the accelerator accelerated
revolution you're describing because so
much of the emphasis was placed on these
collective interactive procedures was
there a specific attitude about objects
for the artists that were showing
sexually to leave the objects invent
communication as a kind of field of
subject it was what exactly was a
question like how they perceive this
another way I mean it's a different
question but may be related in some
degrom unit very one thing I didn't save
it but handsome who like these artists
was a very very committed to the
possibility of a socialist revolution
yeah and actually you know desperately
wanted to participate and in the
construction of any environment that
would be appropriate to this and he was
like why prohibited from playing that
out yes and and and this is in effect
the moment that he ceased to operate as
an architect and began to teach in an
art school and I don't know that you
know was to suggest that he would be
less controversial there but I think
it's very interesting that the clinic
also believed in the possibility of an
idea of of socialism that was in fact
not the Dom mean obviously not the
dominant form in that which it was
unable to play out maybe yes yes it was
okay I'm now can continue and so they
they were down in the students of Hanson
who were thinking in such a large scale
the other students of Hanson were really
thinking like private private gallery
space they had this project of
modernization like Hansen from
architecture they also took this kind of
approach to reality that thinking in the
scale of the car
tray of the socialist system so it was
really important that they wanted to
also take this scale from architecture
and apply it to fine arsenal and this
revolution this new modes of
communication were also kind of placed
in such as K they were meant to operate
in scale of the society that's why we
are in our exhibition with mark we we
are showing a lot of TV programs they
are they are kind of visions of
television of like cinematography so
this dominant made media which they try
to influence they try to promote this
concept of open forum of open forum in
directed artistic practice like Cannes
interactions in a larger social sphere
they wanted to use this mass media to
promote this this art which they thought
as a truly socialist art for them kind
of art which makes improve social
communication which kind of focuses on
kind of grassroots communication which
helps people to self-organize to kind of
be more creative like it's in essence
socialist so and I thought that this
open forum is
is socialist by itself a bloody dead but
by its essence they they they were not
essentialist but they did they'd fall so
about dog inform and a proposed it to to
this day they for that socialist state
should take it as our visual art because
and because it was for them also obvious
that it should be promoted by these days
it should be drinking should replace
this art which stated preferred it was
like conventional figure out the guard
and like to also stress that they they
they referred to this russian
avant-garde of the 20s so probably it
was the last last moment and the last a
vanguard which tried to really connect
this revolutionary artistic ideas with
which state sometimes we we analyzing
Russian Revolution and many artists in
the West also refer to this art radical
political art we kind of forget that
this Bolsheviks like this Russian
Communist artist they thought about they
are art like closely with with with in
connection with a steak with a state
official politics so and here we have
the same situation this exactly this
scheme is repeated and also the
consequence recardo the end of the story
is also similar so they were rejected by
the state and severely punished it's not
exactly the same situation the sense
that I often let's say in ministry
in countries that are like for example
in berlin bluebird based my building was
based on formerly a place that was
called linen closet linen pants and
right next to it there is Karl Marx
plots after 1989 Lennon class was
renamed united nations plaza carmax was
stayed the same and it's very clear why
let him was always perceived as an
imposed figure cominius was always
something that was imposed from the
outside right that kind of disappears
later the so you know like a lot of the
Russian army garden you know after the
Revolution they really embraced it as
their own it was not an imposition in
Poland there was always this moment of
occupation you know nothing the case of
this artist hmm that's very existence is
interesting that they were from his
comics fans and the system it was not
the case of raava cosmic and the rest of
the Polish avant-garde years they
perceived the system as imposed but this
art is not for them it was their system
they want is very you think that it
results in the production that's on many
levels very very similar you know this
kind of completely anti-communist
tendency and this desire for the better
socialism for to improve socialism
actually develops into a very similar
practice I mean there is a kind of
interesting paradox in there no yes of
course
it's also interesting that in London in
the late 60s Marxism was being embraced
you know though I mean mikunis was
embracing the the Russian revolutionary
ideas of the tour of the early you know
18 to early 20s but in in London it was
it was it was Marxism and that's kind of
paradoxical given and of course people
like RD Laing who were very important
with that alternative psychiatry and all
of that that was a that was a very
important issue in London as well but I
think sort of compare edocs call that in
New York you have someone like machinist
doing something very similar to what's
going on in Poland being in Eastern
Europe and you know coming from Eastern
Europe yet in London there was a sort of
very idealistic embracing the dire I
remember throughout the 70s late 70s of
Marxism trotskyism I mean there is
another maybe if we have another second
yeah sometimes for his gross tix about
the opposition within their position for
example when he talks about Moscow
conceptualism he describes him as you
know there was kind of a very large
underground art scene which was mainly
dedicated to production of very
uninteresting objects kind of
modernistic looking painting still life
things like that right and they were
kind of rejecting the official socialist
realism style and within that group of
underground artist was a group of kind
of rejection is the winner rejection
that actually embraced socialist ways of
representation the visual language etc
like avakov and in the end this kind of
internal group made quite interesting
cultural production in a way you're
talking about this group of artists and
worse so it seems it's almost some kind
of an opposition for in opposition
but it's different it of course of
course they were embracing you know in
Russia and Soviet Russia the Kabakov and
the others they were kind of ironically
ironically with this state official
propaganda and this artist they proposed
the replacement of this statement
promotin propaganda with the Vanguard
art is like I offer fabulous so let's
take up the offer them of the alucard
replacement for the state and take up
the offer of a drink over in the gallery
thank you very much